Solo Leveling - D-Rank Dungeon Arc - Introduction
Arc
Hey everyone Diavolo here and today we are
jumping into a completely different series
that i've seen a bunch of you requesting down
below.
Solo Leveling is one of those journeys where
we follow one man on his quest to become the
strongest in a constant battle against both
man and monsters.
Unlike a bunch of manga that I shan't name,
this Manhwa doesn't stray into the confusing,
philosophical or profound.
Instead its extremely easy to read and lets
the art along with the brilliant fight scene’s
take a hold.
Dont get me wrong, the story also has a great
deal of substance and interesting concepts,
they just dont make that the focus.
The focus is always seemingly on Jin-Woo and
his quest to become the strongest.
In this video we are going to cover the first
Arc that takes place throughout the series,
D-Rank Dungeon Arc.
This arc is a fantastic way to enter the world
of Solo Leveling.
While focusing on the main character, his
initial strengths and weaknesses, we are slowly
fed information that allows us to gain an
even greater understanding of the world that
everyone finds themselves in.
It seems to be one like our own, however 10
years earlier a random event happened led
to a massive change in the world!
If you want to find out more, Subscribe, push
this video to 3k likes so I know you want
the next arc and sit back and relax as we
delve into the first part of Solo Leveling!
Chapter 1
Kicking things off in Seoul, South Korea,
apologies all my Hyung’s for what's probably
a terrible accent for Korean pronunciation.
Either way, we find the worlds weakest hunter,
E-Rank Sung Jin-Woo.
Walking through the streets, brooding over
his ridiculously weak self, Jin finds its
embarrassing to even call himself a hunter.
His life is always on the line, he takes a
brutal amount of damage and has almost died
a few times.
Being a hunter is a Job where you place your
life on the line in the hopes of great return,
however Jin isn't doing this because its a
choice.
Meanwhile, in a construction site, the infamously
known weakest hunter, Sung Jin-Woo, arrives
to join the other hunters in the raid.
Looking over at him walk past, one returning
hunter, Bak questions if he’s powerful as
everyone is happy to see him!
Kim though points out that its the opposite,
he’s the worlds weakest and finds it tough
to even get through an E Rank dungeon.
Figuring that since he’s here its most likely
an extremely weak dungeon, Kim tells his boy
to quiet his voice since he might over hear
them, to which its revealed that Jin had heard
the entire convo.
Trying to clear his mind, Jin asks for a coffee
however to his dismay finds that they just
ran out.
Feeling absolutely terrible, the dude apologizes
and Jin walks off a bit let down.
All of a sudden Ju-Hee screams out noticing
that he’s all beaten up!
Sitting down together, the two chat for a
brief moment about how Jin was sent to the
hospital following an expedition into an E-Rank
dungeon.
Getting up, Jin tells her they mise aswell
head over since it looks like everyone's about
to head in.
Gathering everyone around, Song Chiyul, asks
if its alright to take the role as team leader
for this raid!
Everyone agree’s and shortly following this
he heads inside, telling everyone to follow
him forth into the Dungeon.
Gaining confidence, Jin-Woo tells himself
to try his best today and enter the portal
last behind everyone.
Chapter 2
Watching everyone leave, the dude from the
coffee stand tells his boy that he feels a
bit s**t since he wasn't able to give Jin
a coffee before he headed in!
Now in the dungeon, Jin-woo is found already
being healed by Joohee and apologizing for
his lack of skills.
All around them the other members of the group
take care of the remaining monsters.
Thinking that the raid is almost done, Jin-woo
looks over to see everyone in a group talking.
Above their heads you can see a symbol representing
something, these different colors and symbols
each correlate to a members affinity.
Snapping him back, Joohee asks if he has a
reason?
one stopping him from leaving?
Not wanting to reveal his own personal hell,
Jin laughs while expressing that he does this
for the fun of it.
Otherwise he’d die of boredom.
Song holding a crystal in his hand explains
that this thing is a magical core, an item
someone receives after killing a monster.
Magical cores from even a C-Rank monster is
worth thousands, yet sadly since Jin is an
E-Rank hunter.
C-Ranks are a mere impossibility for him to
achieve.
Holding the pathetic E-Rank core in his hand,
Jin thinks its a bit small after putting his
all into this dungeon.
As he becomes even more disheartened, a random
yells out that they found another entrance!
Standing infront of the gaping cave entrance,
Song explains that the thing infront of them
is most likely a double lair!
Sparking up his magical flames, Song beautifully
twists a torrent of fire and shoots it forth
a distance down the tunnel.
Watching it continue, the flame hits the ground
before slowly fading back to black.
Getting everyone's attention, Song elaborates
that the Gate wont close if the Boss is still
alive.
Due to the gate not closing yet, its evident
that the boss is most likely down the tunnel.
Usually they’d need to contact the guild,
but if other people get to the profits first,
then their own profits will dwindle.
Looking at them all, he instead proposes a
vote on if they should venture forth to kill
the boss.
Since there are 17 of them there it will result
in one side winning and no matter what they
shouldn't complain about what happens.
After a few moments, its shown that the votes
came back 8 to 8 with it all depending on
Jin-woo’s vote if they venture forth.
Knowing he doesn't have enough money and soon
needs to pay for his sister to attend college,
plus look after his sick mother in hospital.
Jin-woo announces that he is going, meaning
that all 17 of the Hunters will push further
into the dungeon.
Chapter 3
Wondering how long its been since everyone
entered the cave, someone mentions that its
been around 40 minutes and the gate will close
an hour after the boss is defeated, so right
now they have about 20 minutes spare to escape!
Walking together, Jin-woo apologies’ to
Joohee for forcing her to come in here after
voting yes!
Being told that he doesn't need to worry,
Jin pushes further to get the truth, only
for Joohee to rage out and tell him that no,
she currently is not okay!
Screaming if he’s mental?
Joohee reveals that the wound Jin initially
received (the one we never saw) was a stab
wound that entered just below where his heart
is.
Coming to see that he really is only alive
because of her, Jin apologizes for dragging
her into it once more.
Smiling, Joohee hints that if he really is
sorry, maybe he should take her out for some
food to prove it!
Blushing, but unable to say anything.
Joohee asks him if he doesn't want to, to
which he snaps out of the daze and accepts
the date.
Finally a few more minutes, the group end
up finding a large golden and purple door.
Asking those following if they want to return
empty handed or not, Song begins pushing the
door open while saying that they could be
the first ones to ever enter this section.
Creaking open and entering the room, blue
flames ignite, alighting the room and revealing
the large circular space that lays before
them.
Excepting to face magic beasts, the team is
confused and notes that it looks as if no
one has been here in ages.
Statues surround the room, some holding weapons,
some holding instruments.
The atmosphere makes Jin’s hair stand on
edge and he feels as if someone’s staring
down on him.
Not wanting to be caught up with negative
feelings, Jin examines the massive statue
that’s seated in the center back of the
room.
He assumes it isn't the boss, as its only
a statue, however its the only one this large.
Looking down, Song randomly finds a moss covered
magic seal.
Yelling out to him, another of the crew calls
him over to read some ancient text.
Moving over to the text board, Song begins
reading out Carthenons Temple Commandments.
FIRST, worship the lord....
SECOND, praise the lord....
THIRD, prove your faith!
Being tapped on the shoulder, Jin turns around
to hear Joohee exclaiming that the statue’s
eyeball just moved.
Thinking that she’s tripping, suddenly Jin
starts to feel an aura he hadn’t before.
The air became chill and all noise stopped.
With that Song announces to the group that
anyone who does not follow the previously
mentioned rules, will never return alive...
Slamming behind them, everyone’s heads snap
back to see that the previously open entrance
has slammed shut.
Annoyed with everyone spouting nonsense, one
of the team members announces that he’s
outa there, they can have whatever treasures
they find, but he’s done.
Wishing them goodluck, he places his hand
apon the door only to hear Song scream out
for him to wait!!!
Before his voice even reaches the hunter,
a shadow shoots through the room and cleaves
the man down.
Instantly following this, the statue returns
to its position and lowers the weapon.
Horrified to witness the statue coming to
life, the team members are left speechless
knowing that if they want to leave, they need
to beat them!
Jin-woo remembering a previous statement,
flicks his head around to see the main statue
staring right back at him!
Chapter 4
Thinking about the guy who just died, Jin
knows he was only D-Rank.
Even if he was a weak D-Rank, he still would've
been stronger than an E-Rank like himself.
For those confused with the ranking system.
Simply it starts at E, then D, C, B, A and
finally the strongest at S rank.
The anime has done things slightly differently
as you could tell.
Not with the power system, its instead added
a few other interactions with other characters
that never happed in these initial chapters.
I think its good, cause it expands the world
a little bit more, however I hope they stick
with mainly Jin’s pov and dont get caught
up in other things to early on.
The pacing is looking like 4 - 5 chapters
per episode, so we will get 55 to 60 chapters,
possibly even more throughout this first season!
Anyways Anyways!
Confused because this dungeon was meant to
be D-Rank at most, Jin swears that he’s
never heard of monsters as strong as these
inside of a D-Rank dungeon.
In a flashback we find that this wasnt the
first time Jin almost died.
During the first raid he ever went on, he
accidentally left the group and got lost.
Then outa no-where a random E-Rank goblin
shanked him from behind, sending him to the
hospital for weeks!
Another time he almost starved to death after
being trapped inside.
Other people in the solo leveling world usually
use their magical cores to trade up for better
weapons, to then fight stronger monsters and
earn even more money!
Jin cant do this though.
He never holds a weapon.
It would just break anyway.
Having a healer means his injuries' would
be able to get healed, but only if it wasn't
to extreme.
That though means they have to work twice
as hard, babysitting some weakling who can
barely look after himself.
Every time he got injured and heard their
sneering remarks.
All the times he continued a job that may
result in his demise.
Maybe it was all for this moment...
Reacting just in time, Jinwoo screams out
for his comrades to duck.
Hearing his warning some hunters stand there
stationary, watching the statue's eye’s
begin to glow.
Suddenly a beam of light is sent out that
utterly eviscerates anything in its path.
Opening their eyes and seeing what remains
of the group, the hunter's horror only furthers
as they notice that a large portion of them
were taken out.
Making himself heard, Song yells for everyone
to not stand up and remain in their positions.
If they choose to stand back up, the statue
will attack them again!
With everyone listening, Song creeps over
to Jin and lets him know that even though
Juhee is a B-Rank healer, she cant handle
fear at all.
While talking with Song, Jin notices that
almost all of his fellow hunters arm was blown
off by the previous attack.
Asking to be bandaged up, Song looks up at
the giant statue and questions his boy what
rank it looks like it could be to him.
Not knowing, due to never having stepped foot
in a dungeon higher than D-Rank, Song who’s
experienced B-Rank a few times is certain
that this being defiantly exceeds that of
a B-Rank boss.
This one though, he guesses that it could
possibly be a S-Rank creature.
Thinking on the spot, Jin remembers the commandments
that song read out earlier.
Worship the lord, Praise the lord and prove
your faith!
Those who do not follow the commandments will
never return alive.
To Jin, its obvious.
He thinks that the giant godlike statue seated
infront of him, is that lord.
Chapter 5
In Solo Leveling, these dungeons exist in
a different time space or dimension.
To get there, something called a Gate needs
to be used.
This Gate is a sort of tunnel that connects
other random worlds to their own.
10 years earlier after the first gate randomly
appeared in the world.
Many people begun to experience random events.
One of these random events to happen were
the modification of humans into hunters.
The moment a hunter is chosen, their strength
stays the same and is impossible to change.
Jin too became a hunter, however his strength
was only enough for an E-Rank rating.
Still Jin is stronger than most individuals,
its just that the difference between him and
other ranks is drastic.
The men and women who received the powers
to cross the gate and destroy monsters as
a career were labeled as ‘Hunters’.
Sometimes, on odd occasions.
Beyond the gate, there can be an, ominous...
despairing...
Insane monster that comes out of no-where.
Wondering if he’s going to be okay, Jin
asks if the bleeding will stop, but Song says
there really isn't much they can do now.
Initially he’d brought 3 healers here because
he thought this would be over quickly.
Now though, one got literally vaporized by
the first attack and the other is so shocked
that he’s unable to move.
Even the B-Rank healer Joohee has never experienced
anything like this, so its making healing
slightly difficult for the time being.
For Song, he thinks that the best course of
action is to stand still, then once the situation
clears a tad, try and make a run for it.
Suddenly one of the random hunters breaks
away from the group while claiming that this
isn't his final moment, he finally managed
to join a big guild, so he wont die here.
Gritting his teeth, the man gasses himself
up and plans to use enough speed to burst
through the door in an instance.
Boosting off and sending rocks flying with
tremendous speed, the hunter begins closing
in on the door.
All of a sudden a burst of light shoots through
the room, evaporating the hunter and leaving
nothing but his feet remaining.
Groaning with rage, another hunter questions
why it is that the monsters are taking their
time when they could just take them out whenever
they feel like it.
Thinking that this is completely different
from the typical monsters who just blindly
attack on sight.
Jin is able to deduce that the statues seem
to attack in a sort of pattern.
Snapping his head back towards something,
he figures that it has to be, there has to
be a rule to how this room works.
Analyzing the Commandments Of Carthenon Jin
realizes this is the exact key to surviving
the room.
Asking what the first commandment was, Song
reminds him that it was to worship the lord.
Pondering what this could possible mean, Jin
starts to get up while explaining that there
is a rule to this dungeon.
Chapter 6
Making his way towards the statue, Jin watches
as the eyes begin to glow and immediately
drops to the floor, sweat starting to drip
from his brow.
Seeing the eye’s glow fade, he assumes that
the being will start to attack if the targeted
person moves past a specific height.
Understanding an aspect of the statue, Jin-woo
tells everyone to bow down before it!
Wondering if he’s gone mad or something,
Song asks if he managed to figure something
out?
Replying yes, Jin explains that like i've
said the being attacks those who pass a certain
height.
The phrase ‘worship the lord’, literally
means bow down and worship him!
Following the E-Rankers orders, everyone bows
down and begins worshiping the statue infront
of them.
Looking down on them, the light from the statues
eyes randomly disappears.
Snapping opening, the concrete grin of this
grotesque being opens and its eyes turn red,
ominously looking down on all of the fodder
hunters below it.
Feeling its gaze violating them, Jin wonders
how many this creature has attacked in the
past?
How many people in their group are still alive?
How long do they have to lay down here and
do this?
Starting to rise, Bak thinks the creatures
stopped and instead of continuing to make
them bow will try something else soon.
He doubts that just because they bowed down
everything is going to turn out fine.
One by one everyone slowly rises to their
feet after seeing that the monster has indeed
stopped attacking.
Suddenly the room begins to shake and the
statue itself begins rising from the seat.
Stomping on the floor, everyone looks up in
horror, knowing that this entire fiasco isn't
over.
Towering above them like a monolithic demonic
god, all the hunters stand their in fear unable
to move or say anything.
Stepping forth, Song screams at Jin for any
more ideas?
but due to the frantic nature of the dungeon
he’s unable to think of anything.
Quickly snapping out of it he remembers the
rules that he started going over earlier.
Knowing that next in the line of commandments
was to praise the lord, Jin guesses that it
has to be the key to solving this.
Speaking up another random hunters announces
that he’s got this.
Back in the day he was a member of a church
choir, so his lungs are literally built for
praising!
Grabbing ahold of his cross, the hunter closes
his eyes and starts to approach the Lord.
Not stopping under fear of death, the hunter
sings for the Lord to make him anew!
As everyone stands around, they wonder if
its working or not and Bak even thinks the
dudes moving slightly slower now.
Jin though, mans dripping in a cold sweat
since he’s come to realize the hunter is
praying to the wrong God!
With that, the statue steps down, flattening
the ex Christian below its gigantic foot.
Chapter 7
Screaming and turning away in fear of the
seemingly inevitable, some people even decide
to start running away in hopes of living for
just a moment longer.
Terrorfied and unable to move, Joohee screams
her final words as the statue squishes her
too.
Jk though, big simping Jin was able to double
back and tear her away in time.
Running now Song tells everyone to split up
in an attempt to figure out what to do.
By himself, Bak thinks back on his wife and
the life that he had with his family while
re-iterating that he cant die here!
He’s determined to be a father to his two
children, but this is...
Thinking he found a safe location to chill
out, Kim screams out to watch his back and
turn around.
Unable to react in time, the statue cleaved
downwards, slicing our boy Bak in two and
sending him straight to the shadow realm.
Just like before, the statue then returns
to its original position.
Over another side of the room, Jin runs with
Joohee from the statue, wondering how the
hell he’s meant to praise a God he doesn't
know?
Analyzing the room, he knows that the room
is encircled with large guards and a colossal
statue centered at the back.
If one gets to close to a statue, it automatically
attacks them in an instant.
Randomly as he looks at each individual statue
he see’s a woman one holding a trumpet.
Wondering if they attack with instruments
aswell, Jin knows the others only attack if
you get to close.
Once you are close its all a predetermined
move set.
Figuring that he’s probably on the right
track, Jin yells out to the remaining people
to run towards the statues with instruments.
Seeing that he was already next to one, Song
looks over to see the statue begin playing
a dank tune.
Backing up Jin's statement, he tells the others
that the statues holding instruments dont
attack!
Finding a statue of his own, Kim breaks down
over the loss of his close friend Bak.
Honestly pretty rough, dude decided to return
to the hunter life, only to get literally
rick rolled by some demonic gods little game.
Sprinting over to the other side of the room,
both Jin and Joohee stand underneath a man
with a drum, however it refuses to begin playing
until only one remains.
Darting off, Jin makes a mad dash towards
the next closest instrument.
Looking over at the fleeing rat beneath itself,
the statue moves to stomp on Jin.
Telling himself to push just a tad further,
Jin is able to dodge the foot, however the
subsequent stomp sends him uncontrollably
tumbling forwards.
Stunned and unable to move, Jin can only watch
as he slides straight towards a shield wielding
statue.
Thrusting downwards, the statue seemingly
pushes its shield into the ground and destroys
the concrete floor as Jin slides into it.
Joohee screams out in a hope that he some
how made it out alive.
Bloody and barely able to move now, Jin pleads
with whatever force is above for something
to appear infront of him.
Rising to his feet and holding onto the thread
that connects him to Life or Death...
He slowly starts to feel like now... even
that may break...
Closing his eyes, the voice of an angel suddenly
begins singing out!
Below it we see that our boy, laid out has
somehow managed to get lucky and find a statue.
Laughing at the luck he seems to have.
We then see that due to all of the music being
played or song being sung, the Lord has stopped
dead in the center of the room.
Moments later, Joohee sprints over to Jin
and asks him if he’s alright!
Jin tries saying he’s alright, however after
arriving and seeing the terrible state he’s
currently in, Joohee breaks down.
Chapter 8
Feeling terrible and probably thinking its
her fault that Jin lost his foot, Joohee puts
her all into making sure that the wound is
healed!
Outputting to much magic blood spurts from
her nose and she collapses next to Jin.
Thankful that atleast Jin somehow managed
to survive, Kim points out how the groups
numbers are quickly being whittled away.
From 17 to only 6 and 2 of those surviving
members are already gravely injured.
Finding it unfortunate that Song lost his
arm, Kim reminds him that this is all because
he made a rash decision as the party leader.
Warning him about the impending punishment
for losing so many members, Song, heavy hearted,
agree’s with what he’s saying.
Moving once more, everyone's attention is
quickly brought back to the statue.
Raising its left hand, everyone feels the
ground shake uncontrollably, before infront
of them a table like object burst through
the floor.
Once the summoned platform finishes forming,
flames then also appear in the sky around
the outskirts of the room.
Looking at the summoning infront of them,
Kim wonders what it could be, only for Jin
to say that its an altar.
Elaborating to the other 5 members, he assumes
its one from like an ancient mythology where
they sacrificed living beings for their lord.
Backing his assumption up, he re-iterates
that the final commandment was to prove your
faith!
Suddenly a light appears in the stomach of
Kim and the man begins with drawing his blade
from a small gateway like opening.
Even though he thinks he’s dumb, Kim understands
this likely means they need to sacrifice someone!
Pointing his sword towards the gravely injured
Song, Kim demands that the man who brought
them here step forwards.
In his mind, Kim feels like Song is responsible
for all 11 deaths that have happened so far.
Plus he also just agreed to take responsibility
before.
Seeing where he’s coming from, Song agree’s
on taking responsibility but asks for him
to lower the sword and let him walk ahead
freely.
Jin full on disagrees with what's going on,
in his mind he doesn't think its his fault,
they all voted to come here and its just cowardly
to turn it around and say its his issue now.
Stumbling upto the altar, Song stare’s down
at the at the weirdly decorated pattern on
top of it.
Randomly a normal flame ignites behind him
causing Kim to scream out and ask what the
hell is happening now?
Confused himself, Jin asks if this isn't what
they were supposed to do?
Unable to understand what the flame means
or if the god wanted a sacrifice, Jin asks
the remaining 4 people infront of him if they
could carry him up to the altar?
Being carried in by the large guy and other
female, Jin notices that as soon as they enter
the circle 3 more flames ignited.
Asking Song if he thinks the others will save
them if they decide to stay here?
Song begins explaining a feature of how these
gates work.
For them right now it marks one week since
the gate was opened.
The statues will start moving before reinforcements
even get close to this part of the dungeon.
The reason this even matters is because after
1 week of being open, monsters inside of the
gate can come through.
The entire purpose of a raid to begin with
is to kill the boss and close the gate before
time runs out.
If the people inside of the dungeon fail these
tasks right now, it will mean the monster
commanding them to do all these random tasks
can get free into their world.
Turning to the final two members, Jin tells
them that they should come here aswell.
For every person that steps on the altar,
a flame appears and in his eyes means the
trial wont begin until everyone’s on it.
Listening to him and proceeding to stand on
the altar themselves, blue lights suddenly
shoot along the ground out to the outer edge
of the altar where it lights a corresponding
blue flame.
Looking at the ant sized people below it,
the statue waves its hand causing the door
over the other side of the room to swing open.
Standing there stunned, everyone wonders what
the hell they should do now!
Adding to the already tense situation, every
stone statue around the circumference of the
room slowly begins enclosing in on the group.
Chapter 9
Randomly, Jin looks from statue to statue
and see’s their movement cease the moment
his eyes look at them.
Turning to Joohee he tells her that she cant
close her eyes here, its just like when they
were kids.
The statues will only move when you take your
eyes off them.
Kinda like those coil heads from lethal but
the movement speed is nerfed.
Closing her eyes in fear and listening to
the statue take another step, the other female
hunter screams out in terror before darting
off in an attempt to escape.
Once she leaves the circle one of the flames
around the outside vanish of the altar vanish
and she seemingly runs through the doorway
unharmed.
Absolutely confused with what the hell they
witnessed, everyone questions Jin how she’s
alive?
Plus on top of that when she did exit, the
door slightly closed.
Trying to think, Jin presumes that a blue
flame disappears after a set amount of time.
One of the red flames that appeared based
on the number of people, also vanished the
moment she left the circle.
Due to how straightforward the rules have
been so far, Jin comes to the conclusion that
the open door is a trap, a false hope.
The door only opened after the red flames
appeared and closes just slightly every time
one of the same flames disappear.
Prove your faith for Jin is literal.
Meaning that even in terror and danger, with
the sweetest of temptations, keep your faith
true!
Apologizing to Jin, the big dude who carried
him over earlier says he doesn't think he
can take much more of this.
Throwing Jin to the floor and leaving him
helpless, the man runs off towards a supposed
false hope.
Watching another leave, Kim is just baffled
that once again, someone just ran out.
Screaming out that NO ONE CAN MOVE!
Jin explains if any less than the amount of
people they currently have leave, the rest
wont be able to survive.
Needing an elaboration on what's happening,
Song asks Jin for more info, to which he tells
him all they need to do is stay still and
watch the statues until the flames disappear!
The blue flames are a timer and once they
run out everyone will be able to leave!
Kim tells him that yeah he may be right, but
the door could also slam shut sealing them
in here when the flames run out.
Throughout all the previous dungeons he’s
gone through with Jin, Kim never imagined
someone as weak as him would be helpful.
He always looked down on him and never really
expected anything from him.
A lot of people initially died when they got
here, but the ones who are alive are because
of his quick thinking.
Kim thanks him for everything so far, however
as he throws his sword to the ground begins
tearing up.
He reveals he also has a family and doesn't
want to die yet!
Not being able to take the fear of death anymore,
Kim apologizes one more time, before leaving
the circle and making a run for freedom.
With tears in his eyes, Jin drops to the floor
utterly pissed off with everyone's apparent
selfishness.
Now that Kim's run, the remaining 3 have no
chance.
Its doomed them to a cruel death.
Chapter 10
Looking defeated, Song points out that the
doors nearly closed.
Its too late now, but he finally understands
what's going on.
Knowing that the door wont close as long as
there’s at least one person on the altar,
Song tells the others to leave, since they
naturally have a lot more life to live.
Turning to Joohee, he asks if she’d be able
to help Jin out of the room, to which she
instantly agrees!
Sadly though, Joohee collapses to the floor
before she’s even able to attempt picking
Jin up.
Seeing her legs shaking, Joohee cries out
that they wont move!
Sadly and due to Joohee using to much Mana
in an attempt to heal Jin, she’s exhausted
herself to the point she can no longer move.
Taking the old dudes place, Jin tells him
that he should instead take Joohee out of
here.
Disagreeing Song tries saying that he’ll
stay but obviously Jin points out that no
one will be able to carry Joohee, plus there’s
no time so they need to run!
Screaming out that she’d rather stay here,
Jin reminds her that he promised he’d buy
her dinner...
Pulling out his pathetic E-Rank core, Jin
tells her to eat the dinner first.
Then once he returns, he’ll find her for
payment.
Going to say something, Joohee is quickly
knocked out as Song picks her up and tells
Jin there really isn't any more time to wait.
Asking the old man to take care of her, Song
promises that he will, before slowly making
his leave with Joohee.
Seeing them escape through the door to safety,
Jin thanks god as at least he’s the only
one that’s dying now.
(Interesting aspect aswell, think about how
in that moment he weirdly ‘praises god’.
Idk is something i've just noticed as i've
begun scripting the series.
Its almost unintentional from his side, but
im curious as to if it held any credence).
Anyways
Feeling like an idiot, Jin beats himself up
over not having got a life insurance incase
of this happening.
Looking over and seeing Kim's sword on the
ground, Jin picks it up and decides that in
his final moments he’s gonna take at least
one of these monsters down with him.
Bloodshot eyes and completely unable to stand
due to his missing foot, Jin points the blade
forth and tells the monsters to ‘come’.
In a flash, the closest monster strikes down
on Jin, ripping through his chest with complete
ease.
Coughing blood and screaming in pain, the
monster doesn't stop.
Instead it removes its spear, flinging Jin
up into the air.
Falling down atop the altar, and barely breathing
now, our boy exclaims, he doesn't want, doesn't
want to die!
Tears pour from his eyes and thoughts begin
to rush his mind.
‘This isn't fine’ ‘What do you mean
thankful?’
Done with everything, he questions why everyone
betrayed him?
He also has a family...
He also doesn't want to die...
Remembering he said he’s glad that he’s
the only one dying.
Jin tells himself he’s a freaking liar.
He... he never wanted to die.
Now laying there and watching his life come
to its close, Jin wishes that he had just
one more chance.
STRIKING DOWNWARDS!
Suddenly the entire altar erupts with a plethora
of different lights and flames.
The blade from the statue slowly begins to
come to a stop, until it ceases, stuck...
Randomly a screen appears above Jin.
Confused he wonders what the hell this could
be?
Looking closer, the random screen reads Alarm!
You sir are dank and have completed all necessary
requirements of the secret quest!
‘Courage Of The Weak’
Still acting blazed cause dudes got a hole
in his chest, Jin cant seem to even comprehend
what just happened.
Suddenly another screen pops up asking if
he will accept the right to become a player.
Then another reminding him that he doesn't
have much time at all remaining.
If he actually refuses this random request,
then his heart will stop approximately 0.02
seconds after.
Realizing that if he accepts, he doesn't need
to die.
Jin takes it!
Welcoming him as player, Jin's bruised, cut
and limp body is suddenly engulfed by beams
of light so bright he’s physically hidden
from view.
Outro
Well I guess that is one way to end the first
arc of the series, on a more or less cliffhanger
WHICH like we all know dudes fine.
Otherwise idk what all this light novel jargon,
or the almost 100 chapters of a webtoon would
be about.
Though it would be funny man if man killed
his main character at chapter 10 then decided
to re-create him.
I guess that is kinda what happens in a way,
like man was 0.2 seconds off dying and well
if you’ve seen what comes next, mans a completely
new person.
Speaking of next, if you have all enjoyed
this D-Rank Dungeon arc for Solo leveling,
then make sure to push this video to 3000
likes so I know you all want more and check
out the webcomic for yourselves, its a really
easy read.
No brain power needed at all, its just the
typical brute fest and I love that.
Of course if you happen to be new around here
aswell, then subscribe and check out the multitude
of different series i've covered now!
Either way thank you all for 200k again its
actually insane, but for now its been your
professional degenerate Diavolo and ill see
you all in a bit, bye!